each month I create one of these update
videos and load it into my main youtube
channel so I can inform my viewers and
subscribers about what took place last
month and what we've got coming up in
the month ahead this time I'm further
behind than I've ever been it's now the
9th of March but you should pretend that
this video is actually being uploaded on
the first of March and I could talk
about it as if it is I always like to
begin with a few highlights so I've got
three pieces of particularly big news
the first of them is that I've created a
patreon site for the half hour hagel
video series which now is projected
realistically to be a multi-year project
to say the least but i'll talk more
about that later on but if you're
interested in contributing to support
this project which is going to develop a
very innovative digital resource that
will be used i think for generations to
come there's there's an opportunity to
do so you can see the link in the
description below the second piece of
really big news is that I've been
brought on by the global Center for
Advanced Studies to become a faculty
member teaching in their Institute of
critical philosophy they like the sort
of stuff that I do in both continental
philosophy and in the history of
philosophy I'm going to be designing
foundations classes and then a number of
other things for their curriculum that
they're currently building and a number
of figure classes as well so that's
that's another piece of big news and
i'll talk more about that in a bit and
then finally I had a really excellent
talk down at Columbia University about
Aristotle anger practical rationality
and so why don't I just jump right into
februari since I always begin by talking
about the lectures and workshops that
I've given that month so in February I
had three talks two of them were local
and I finished up the month with a talk
down at Columbia I was invited by the
undergraduate forum to give them some
you know
discussion of something that I'm doing
in my current research and so I picked
Aristotle and how anger seduces
practical rationality actually called it
sweeter than honey because that's a
phrase that Aristotle uses to discuss
how anger works and how it feels for for
many of us so I ended up going way
longer than i thought it would there
were a lot of excellent student
questions as a matter of fact the
session went on for almost two hours so
long that the video camera actually ran
out of power I did manage to get all of
it recorded on my iPhone in a sound file
so if you're watching you know that
video towards the very very end you
notice that the the camera goes out but
they're still sound and it was a really
great day i went down i took the train
down from from kipp see down to Grand
Central took the subway up to the
Columbia got to spend some time with the
friend of mine and colleague who invited
me down there who I've got a lot in
common with he's you know although we
were in different services he's a fellow
vet and you know very into philosophy
got to walk around Colombia see some
some of the sites spend some time with
him and get to meet his family and then
address the the undergraduate forum so
that was a great time I did two other
talks up here in Kingston both of them
hosted by the Kingston Public Library
one was another of the anger talks in
the series understanding anger this
monthly lecture series that I'm doing
very well attended we probably had about
20 people brave the cold and come out on
a Saturday morning to hear about Jewish
Scriptures on anger and next month we're
actually moving ahead with that but
we've now done ancient Greek epic and
tragedy we've done Jewish Scriptures and
now we're moving into some philosophical
works we also started something
completely new a you might call it it's
it's it's something that we're not so
much doing talks for as as leading
community discussion it's a
reconsidering series and I've paired up
with
this this a friend and colleague Abdul
guy and also my wife Andy Chaka and
we're going to be bringing in some other
people as well into these discussions we
give short talks during them so i gave a
talk about Martin Luther King and just
and unjust law because we were doing
reconsidering Ferguson where there's
this oppressive legal regime in place
that is highly discriminatory I'm do guy
you talked about Sojourner Truth but we
had a lot of other really interesting
discussions going on as well so those
were the talks been doing a lot of work
in February on classes like I said I got
appointed to the faculty of the GPS the
global Center for Advanced Studies and I
have been developing the first class for
them that they really have a need for a
foundations class something like an
intro to philosophy class but set up
exactly the way that I think it ought to
be introducing students to key thinkers
key themes main areas of philosophy and
even a bit about how to do research in
the Internet age on philosophy so that
is actually set to run a beginning of
April so if you're interested in that
class I will be posting information
about it once it's actually placed into
their their their system that'll happen
later on this week I'm sure Maya player
know existentialism class long-waited
began the very beginning of februari
we're now in week six we've looked at
Kierkegaard Dostoevsky Nietzsche real
kit and we're starting left chest off
this week that's going very well I
started another section of marist world
views and values after finishing up a
previous section and I've got a whole
crop of students about 30 of them at
class so that that's some good stuff as
well I've been doing some some writing
some academic writing and also some
blogging not quite as much as I would
have liked to have done but you know
it's hard to find the time and the
energy at the end of the day to do that
video work so
I do have to apologize because I feel
like I've been stringing viewers along
saying hey more critical thinking videos
are coming out this month and I haven't
done it for two months it's been because
I've got so much other stuff going on
but I do need to add some things to the
new channel half-hour Hagel I released a
number of those videos and of course
produce those in February we finished up
the section on sense certainty the first
section of the phenomenology of spirit
so I'm very excited about that I have
also been taking and people don't know
about this because I'm doing it sort of
on the sly I've been taking my older
existentialism videos where the sound
wasn't quite so good and maybe even let
the lighting wasn't that good and i've
been i've been re-editing them and
putting in section breaks you know
putting in some intro music some some
wonderful slides actually that the fit
the theme that we're shocked by a very
talented artist oh maybe reveal who that
is down the line so I've been doing that
that's a lot of that takes a lot of time
and a lot of work doing that editing
work but it's well worth it and I've
been loading them into a new channel
that I'll be unveiling later on probably
end of spring beginning of summer a
history of philosophy channel but I want
to have some more content in there
before I open it up of course there's
the videos of the talks you can see
those below and I've been releasing the
world views and values videos that I
shot for my Maris students but now
opened up to everybody else so there
were quite a few Descartes videos on the
discourse so Martin Luther King videos
on letter from a Birmingham jail and I
have a dream speech and I just started
releasing some Russo videos as well in
the discourse on the origins of
inequality among men what else is going
on in February we managed to secure an
office space here in Kingston and so you
know that's been taking up a bit of time
because there's a lot of things
associated with that I've been doing
some philosophical counseling as well
some consulting work
I can't tell you anything about the
counseling since its kind of fictional
or the consulting work since that's
under wraps as well but I've been doing
a bit more of that recently as well so
let's talk now about March what's what's
coming up and again pretend like we're
at the beginning of the month reset
March 9th just two talks happening this
month or three talks in a certain way if
you understand the meaning of talk in a
very loose sense so let me talk about
the two things that are definitely talks
first in the understanding anger series
at the kingston library we're doing
play-doh and there we're starting to get
into some philosophical discussions
about anger well not quite at the level
of Aristotle or the stoics but we're
starting to see some systematic
systematic inquiry into what makes
people angry all those sorts of things
we're doing another reconsidering event
that is going to be a little bit later
that is reconsidering Charlie Hebdo so
what we're going to be talking about is
freedom of speech in tolerance tolerance
and how far these these sort of limits
should go offense the marketplace of
ideas that's what I'll be talking about
it in my part now the other thing that
you might consider a talk or you might
not depending on how you view talks
because I won't be doing it in person is
a paper of mine is going to be read at
the Cicero nian society which is
happening later on this month it's being
read by a friend of mine Christopher
annandale who volunteered to read it in
my my absence and and said hey you know
you can't make the conference but we'd
love to have your stuff so this is very
generous of them to allow that I'm very
honored but I won't be there actually
answering questions or reading the paper
and there won't be a video of it either
but i will post a link to it in my
academia profile a little bit later this
month classes I'm still building that
that gks global Center for Advanced
Studies foundation class I started on
that last week should be ready to roll
in April and it'll start enrolling
before that so keep your eyes open for
that it's gonna it's going to be a great
class gks has a policy of making classes
as affordable as possible for students
for online education opening up access
to as many people as they can so if
you're interested in that class even if
you're not a GPS student or you know
necessarily going into their program you
might actually like that if I'm somebody
that you wanted to take a class with
this is an opportunity to do it the
existentialism class is continuing as
well that one is actually closed for
enrollment but we're going to be opening
up a new section sometime in the summer
so that that's something to keep an eye
out for MERIS world views and values
just started and those students I got 30
of them in the class they're making
their way right now through Plato's
Republic and then they're going to be
doing Epictetus so some some fun stuff
for them doing a lot of writing this
month not only the Cicero nian society
paper but also some other stuff on
Aristotle some other stuff on and some
even some work on Thomas Hobbes and
Gabrielle marcel i'll be blogging quite
a bit this month as well now let's let's
talk about video and before we go into
video per se I want to talk about the
half-hour hagel project in particular so
i mentioned that i began effectively
what you call a patreon campaign it's
this ongoing thing it's sort of like
kickstarter indiegogo except with
Kickstarter you're trying to raise a
certain amount of money for a project
and it's like a one-time thing and you
know you give rewards for people to
contribute at certain levels for this
it's an opportunity for people to
contribute to to back the project curve
video so if I don't shoot videos I don't
get paid if I do shoot videos I do get
paid and the cool thing about it is it
gave me a lot of time to think about as
i was designing it well you know what
would I what would i do at certain
levels so like you know if I if I get
enough back
all you know take pic the all the ads
off the the half-hour Hagel videos get
enough I'll even invest in some better
video equipment or start stepping up the
production schedule there's also rewards
for the individual viewers at the
different levels and so you know if
you're interested in that sort of thing
take a look at the Patrian site see if
you want to get involved in that if you
do then then you see exactly how to do
it it's very simple I'm going to be
doing some half hour Hagel videos and
releasing things having to do with with
this section perception that follows
uncertainty this month that's what this
month will be occupied with i will be
bringing out critical thinking videos in
the critical thinking logic and
argumentation channel i'm doing those
later this week and so you can see those
coming out more world views and values
videos are going to be released still
have to do some more Russo I've got some
Mary Wollstonecraft on the the
vindication of the rights women coming
out very interesting stuff and all
hopefully by the end of the month be
releasing some Thomas Hobbes world views
and values videos as well I'm going to
keep on working on the existentialism
videos but that that project is kind of
under the radar right now and there will
be the videos of the talks available for
you as well the rest of what I'm going
to be doing this month is trying to
build out the reason I Oh site something
that's been long overdue I'm also doing
some some work with these online
platforms like learnist and curious and
course most but I can't be sure exactly
how much I'll get done on those so there
you go that's what happened during
February's on some really big stuff
that's what's going on in the rest of
march again pretend like this is on the
first rather than the ninth if you're
interested in these things you see the
links below and there we go